we're gonna do a little what's more
likely chris on this thursday edition of
pft live
as a way to kind of preview the week by
focusing on specific
ideas and concepts from the given games
for example
what's more likely aaron donald gets two
sacks
or carson wentz throws fewer than 40
passes
oh by the way wence has gone eight games
straight not including the wild card
play-off that he left early with a
concussion
with 40 or more passes so what's more
likely man
this this is a good one here because i i
i mean
carson wentz you're right i mean that's
the first thing you think about can they
run the ball can they be consistent that
way they got offensive line issues too
and they got yeah like guys that are new
in
interior left tackle aaron donald coming
to town holy cow
uh i guess what i'm gonna say is more
likely here i gotta see it first so i'm
gonna go aaron donald gets two sacks i
gotta see that the eagles can
have an offensive attack where carson
once doesn't throw for 40 or more
attempts that they will run the football
a little bit
i'm thinking this will be the week they
do it if there's a weakness to the rams
a little
it is you can run on them they're not
necessarily big
they're chaotic and fast and explosive
and disruptive and all that
but yeah i got to go with donald's two
sacks right now i don't believe it with
the eagles
he had a sack and four total quarterback
hits against the cowboys
offensively much better than the eagles
offensive line no matter what you do
yeah to to put extra resources on aaron
donald he's still
gonna get past you there's a clip
floating around of him basically picking
up ezekiel elliott and throwing him yes
well that one hit
on the uh the it was ezekiel had to pick
him up on the blitz i believe i think it
was that play
it was comical watching it on sunday
night sitting there live
i mean he's like he made ezekiel it
looked like a toy
the way he flew in the air and fell on
the ground and ezekiel
as we know is rocked up and thick and
dense
aaron donald has he is
he's in the converse he's starting to be
in the conversation for one of the
greatest defensive players ever i just
hope everybody realizes what they're
watching
it's it's that it's no longer like first
ballot hall of famer
he locked that up two years ago now it's
like
whoa is he starting to get into ray
lewis reggie white
lawrence taylor like that's what kind of
force he is it doesn't pop as much
because he's a d
tackle but that's truly the type of guy
he's starting to get into the
conversation with
greg robinson blake bortles
sammy watkins jake matthews
justin gilbert anthony barr
eric ebron taylor lawn odo beckham jr
all taken
before aaron donald in the 2014 draft
and the lions are the ones that should
be kicking themselves
they took ibra thinking that he was
going to be the quasi replacement for
calvin johnson in the passing game from
a production standpoint not
taking his place as a receiver but that
was at the point where they weren't
quite sure what johnson was going to do
they had obvious needs of defensive
tackle
can you imagine how good the lines would
be oh if they'd had
aaron donald with matthew stafford for
the last seven years oh
yeah i mean yes listen he's he's a he's
a game changer
an organization changer whatever it is
uh yeah there's a lot of teams there
that you look at and go
your your history might be a little
different if you if you picked aaron
donald
there was a time early in their
respective careers that i made the
observation on twitter that
the lions should really regret taking
ibra instead of aaron donald and i think
ebon reacted in a negative way to it
well
uh i win that one eric sorry you're
still playing and good for you but aaron
donald is a transcendent talent and
look here's the thing i think it's
possibly both i don't know which is more
likely because
donald's going to get his two sacks and
they're going to harass
carson wentz and he's not going to be
able to get 40 passes off
maybe not i know and or i just would
think
at the very least they'd go wait we
didn't pass protect that well that last
week our quarterback got hit a little
bit
and this group here is just as good at
rushing the passer and getting after
people and just
causing disruption that way run game
would be the best
thing you can do to slow a guy like
aaron donald
down from you know just flying up field
you know people i always see these you
know i know last week a big thing became
aaron
aaron donald's not that great against
you know the run
right there was this whole analytics
thing based out there
yeah he's not a a a like a plug
gap type of defensive tackle that's not
what they ask him to do they're not
asking him to sit in there and
take on double teams and just create a
mosh pit in the middle of the
the offensive line to where nobody can
move no that's not his game
so there are he they ask him to go hey
you see that gap between the guard and
the tackle
we want you to get through there every
time win that one win that win and he
wins and he wins and he wins
sometimes he wins so fast and so quick
that he flies up the field
and it leaves a gap to where he was and
the running back might run and all of a
sudden he makes a cut back
and he goes back to aaron donald is
whole because aaron donald's five yards
up field
and that can there's a lot of issues
there what i'm saying i don't
believe in those analytics because of
what he's asked to do
and then of course the disruption he
causes that leads to other people
getting tackles which was part of the
analytics conversation there
to where again you know numbers are good
and everything like that but
that's one where i would say they were
wrong with trying to say he's like not
one of the better run defenders in all
of the nfl
and i think this is part of the
psychology of the analytics crowd they
all want to try to one-up each other
they don't want to look
smarter than the other one come up with
some new take some new twist
and i saw a clip similar to the point
you're making where
aaron donald so dramatically and quickly
blows up the hole
that the running back doesn't even try
to go that way he
runs into the spot where donald had been
right
and i that's donald's fault no he did
everything he was supposed to do
is he not supposed to blow up the hole
that's his assignment he wins
right they need to and and i think we
saw some flashes of that
what you need to do is have somebody in
position
next to aaron donald to pick up
that note and to plug that hole that's
going to be there
there was a moment the other night and i
think chris collinsworth picked this up
on
on um sunday night football that's the
name of the show it's on nbc anyway
there was a double there was a yeah
there was a double just on the the
number one
show in prime time for 10 years aaron
donald's double team so you put a guy
next to him
because that guy's going to run
scot-free because they're so focused on
aaron donald
the guy next to him goes in untouched so
maybe they're at the point now where
donald is so good
part of your self-scouting of yourself
defensively
is to figure out where these gaping
holes are going to be
created by the wake of aaron donald make
sure someone's there
because an offense can exploit them no
doubt there's no doubt
it's a little that's where they're like
corey littleton their linebacker they
lost and free agency to the raiders
that's where he was great
because he was an athletic really fast
he could diagnose a play
and that's why they like faster type
linebackers mike exactly to what you're
explaining
it's a little bit like the pittsburgh
steelers the same way because they know
they're going to create all this chaos
up front with their defensive line
and it's going to leave some gaps every
now and then to where you need
a guy that can run 4-4 or 4-5 at middle
linebacker
that can go oh wait aaron donald threw
up field i see that gap i know i'm
supposed to be over here but let me fly
over there and try to help and make the
tackle and
and yeah instead of it being a 10-yard
gain it's a three-yard gain
that is how they play you're you're a
little bit like that and the smart teams
when they play the rams a lot of the
times have some design game plan runs to
where
they kind of invite him to just fly up
field and then they try to create things
behind
him to run that and i wouldn't be
shocked if he saw some of that in the
eagles attack this week too just to get
him the hell out of the way so they
don't have to deal with them
well they got to do something because
otherwise it's going to be another long
day for carson wentz a guy who's got a
well-documented injury
history and he got sacked eight times
last week and he was sacked eight times
by the washington football team's front
seven arizona cardinals taking on
washington this weekend what's more
likely andre hopkins gets 12 or more
catches in his second game with the team
he had 14
last week or washington gets five or
more
sacks kyler murray actually got sacked
five or more times in four games last
year so what's more likely
yeah i mean i'm not shocked that kyle
murray got sacked like that first off
they don't protect the ball that well
he at sometimes is going to you know
push the limit as far as because
he's going to go oh i think i can get
around the corner here and run for 40
yards and he might do that
but at times it costs them where
somebody then grabs his shoulder and
pulls him down and he loses eight or
nine yards
you're gonna have to live with some of
that with kyla murray because we saw
when he does run
it can be very exciting and game
changing like last week that run
won the game basically um oh
i don't know where to go here i think
i'm going to go deandre hopkins
gets the 12 plus catches is that crazy
that i'm gonna say that i i can't
believe i'm saying that
but i think in year two kyler murray is
not going to get sacked
five times anymore i think he's too
smart i think they were very smart last
week and getting the ball out of his
hands they got
hopkins a lot of quick throws screens
things like that
then they got settled in and they
started to work it down the field i
think he realizes what he has to do to
keep his team in the game
i'm actually gonna go crazy and say 12
plus catches i can't believe i'm picking
that actually
and also i need to look at his numbers
from last year i
i think he's more willing this year to
cut it loose and run
instead of staying behind the line of
school and waiting for something to
develop when it's there just go
because i think they're comfortable that
he can protect himself down the field
whereas last year you know you don't
want to find out the hard way
that the guy can't protect himself down
the field last week showed us that he's
got the instincts to do it so i'm gonna
i'm gonna agree with you even though
deandre hopkins season high for any game
last year was 11 catches
he's got 14 week one i think it's far
more likely he gets 12
than that washington front gets to kyla
murray five
or more times in that game and that
should be a very interesting game
we would have thought both of those
teams going 1-0 heading into
that contest all right uh next game for
a what's more likely category the
baltimore ravens heading to houston to
take on the texans who like the chiefs
have an extra three days
because they played on the opening
thursday night what's more likely lamar
jackson ravens quarterback defending mvp
has four touchdown passes or tight uh
texans quarterback deshaun watson
has zero touchdown pass i have a hard
time believing deshaun watson won't
throw a one touchdown pass with this
aggressive ravens defense who will give
you some opportunities
they got a pretty good wide receiving
core i know that it wasn't special last
thursday night
but still you know they're a work in
progress here so let's see what they got
but yes
i think i'm going to err on that i think
i'm going lamar jackson has four td
passes because i just have a hard time
thinking
that desean watson won't get at least
one if so if not a little bit more
against this team and how they like to
match up against
wide receivers and everything like that
yeah i agree with you
i think it's more likely that that uh
lamar jackson gets four then deshawn
watson gets zero because i don't think
he's getting zero
i don't know that lamar's getting four
but last year in week 11 when
the ravens blew out the texans it was
four touchdown passes for
lamar and zero for deshaun watson and
that was kind of one of those moments
that just underscored
how good the ravens were we already knew
they were pretty good by week 11
but that was a jarring outcome to see
them completely dismantle the texans the
way they did yeah get together and and
again who did the texans piss off in the
league office
to start their season the best two teams
in football and the ravens
yeah it only goes up from here billy oh
so take heart
uh at least you're getting these two out
of the way and you can build on it from
here
all right patriots and seahawks sunday
night football slated for seattle
although the air quality in seattle who
knows what it's going to do to that game
to be determined what's more likely cam
newton has 15 or more rushing attempts
or
russell wilson throws 35 or more passes
last week
newton had 15 rushing attempts exactly
actually 14 and a kneel down
and russell wilson had 35 throws what's
more likely
oh i i i think i'm going to go
with 35 plus passes by russell wilson
i think i am that's a good one here too
it really is
i think cam will get close to that 15
number again
i think he'll probably get into double
digits but it's a different scheme in
seattle what they play on the defensive
side of the ball
there's almost always eight people at
the line of scrimmage
i think that'll force force
new england to maybe throw the ball a
little bit more last week where they
might have had a run pass option
okay hey this is the look hey i'm going
to run the ball i'm cam newton boom
whatever this week i think they're going
to get some looks where seattle's going
to be like you really want to run into
this front
all these guys we got up here and i
think cam newton's going to be like
check check check let's throw the
football
so i think it'll be a little less than
that plus i think the other thing that i
want to say here is
with the secondary of new england and
again bill
bill bill belichick has started another
theme in nfl football of called play
through your secondary to build your
defense which is
which is brilliant once again but i
think they're you know they go they're
awesome they're going to get in the face
with dk metcalf
and tyler lockett and philip dorsett
and that's gonna in seattle even though
they like to run the ball
i think it's kind of the same thing
they're gonna go away there's too many
people in the box here to run the
football we got man-to-man with dk matt
let's throw the football let's be
aggressive that way
so i'm going to go with the russell
wilson 35 plus passes
i'm going to go with cam has 15 or more
russians okay here's why belichick
created the impression on monday
that all 15 of those rush attempts came
from an
option look right and i i put on my ron
jaworski
frames officially licensed and uh there
were seven design runs
for cam newton there were six runs out
of an option look
out of 13 total option plays
one scramble and one kneel down that's
how he got his 15 runs so i i think they
do
intend to dial up the run and i think
trying to play it off as it was all from
the option and he just hands off
sometimes and sometimes he doesn't
i think they plan on using his legs why
wouldn't they and i i think they'll find
a way to set up that seattle defense
where they
and look it if if they if they are that
close to the line where they take away
both sides of an option yeah where
there's going to be somebody there for
either one then
then the password
and you're going to eventually get the
look where you can do the option they're
not going to put those
that many guys at the line all game long
because cam newton will throw over top
i would think so too this is a good one
i mean really whoever made this up
whatever idiot is back there making this
up in our sheets and everything we got
good options today good job idiot yeah
good great job you idiots
way to go but that was a tough one i
don't know
yeah i don't not for me though cause i
just think that that we're gonna see cam
run a hell of a lot more than we realize
and that that answer from belichick on
monday in hindsight was just a way to
throw people off the scent
i believe yeah all right vikings and
cults both all-in-one both desperate for
a victory what's more likely philip
rivers
throws zero interceptions or two or more
interceptions
i'm gonna go with zero interceptions
if he throws two or more i i gotta i i
gotta be like
what the hell i don't know what what
i'll be i would i really i'm gonna
be like man phillip why are you doing
this to yourself why would you do this i
gotta think he's smart enough to realize
like wait
am i gonna really you know put this same
you know perception or aura i had with
the chargers and that's why i'm not
there anymore now i'm gonna start doing
it here
with the colts and just start this whole
conversation that you can't trust me
and i'm just too loose with the football
and all that i gotta think this week
and especially recognizing that
minnesota's offense stunk last week
in the meaningful part of the football
game that he's got to look at and go
wait i don't need to push the envelope
what the hell am i doing
so i'm depending on him self scouting
myself and
adjusting his play this week if not his
butt's going to be on the bench soon so
he better adjust
here's my take on it and this is not a
game that i have watched yet and i just
saw some highlights and i can't even
remember the highlights of the
interceptions i know cj henderson the
rookie had one
stupid it's stupid here's the thing both
of them were they were they
were the interceptions of like think
about the mindset of the game
they're supposed to win they're supposed
to win easily was it like a frustration
manifestation where
what the hell is going on here you know
you can get a little looser you're in
that mindset that we're supposed to be
winning this game
we're supposed to be completing these
passes and you end up taking a risk you
shouldn't take and you get picked off
i i can't i can't buy that explanation
because
there were i don't know whether that was
i know i'm just trying it was possible
and i'm not trying to say you were wrong
i'm just saying like just for that
scenario you're saying i'm not trying to
attack you i'm just going
they were moving the ball mike up and
down the field he was playing great
he made a number of great throws i mean
really when you look at the good from
the game you go
man phillip rovers and the colts if you
took away those interceptions you go
they must have won by two touchdowns 17
points something like that the way they
moved the ball
so i i would have a hard time thinking
he got frustrated
he just gets over aggressive and greedy
at times
you know he he got fooled by a rookie cj
henderson they were in a coverage out
there
he peeled off the outside receiver and
he had the slot receiver
working it out route and he threw it
without really seeing where the corner
was
and then later on he makes just a tight
throw into like you're just like
that's tight and you don't have a hollow
hallitzer for an arm anymore
so don't make that decision so they were
two like just
bonehead decisions to me and again they
never punted
they they moved the ball at will the
whole day they screwed that game up
uh and yeah to answer your question i
don't think it was out of frustration i
don't think it was
i'm watching the second interception now
that came with 433 left in the game
jaguars leading 24-20 right colts
on their own 31 and there's a kind of a
weird motion
weirder than his normal motion when he
throws the ball but
my god the guy's clearly covered right
uh and again
that may be right that that's one of
those i i don't
look you're trying to make something
happen yeah that's right losing you
don't know why you're losing you weren't
supposed to be losing and sometimes you
just kind of give in to it so
my point is this yeah he's far less
likely to be
frustrated in this one uh because it's a
better team it's a better defense it's a
better offense you know the vikings are
going to score their points
philip rivers needs to settle in and
just make things happen and score some
points but they make it into a shootout
and
if it's a shootout you're more likely to
have more interception
i'm gonna say it's more likely he throws
two or more i i think i think the
vikings
uh are going to have a foot up their
butt all week long from mike zimmer
everybody connected to that defense and
they're going to be challenged to go out
there
and do something positive against philip
rivers so they're facing i think
look last week's minnesota defense was
horrible this week's is going to be
better
and i think they're they're going to get
a couple of interceptions
that's more likely than getting none
against philip rivers all right
last game to take a look at the bears at
1-0 hosting the giants at 0-1 what's
more likely
mitchell trubisky throws three
touchdowns in one quarter
as he did last week or saquon barkley
has under 10
rushing yards uh for the second straight
week
that's more likely i can't imagine
saquon barkley has 10
something rushing yards again now again
like last week we could talk about
saquon all we want you watch the game on
monday night i don't care who the hell
you had
bruce banner and the hulk kind of came
out they weren't going to get any yards
running the football
it's a little different defensive scheme
a little more
stand in your place as compared to
pittsburgh as far as what chicago does
so i would think he gets more than 10
yards so i guess what i'm saying is uh
i think that it's more likely that
trubisky can throw for three touchdowns
in a quarter which i don't know if i
necessarily think is that likely either
but if you're gonna make me pick the out
of the two i'm going to pick that
and we know that the giant's secondary i
don't think is anything special
and i don't think they have a great pass
rush either which can lead to maybe
trubisky having a day that way but this
is one where i look at it i don't think
either one happens
yeah i i agree with you there there's no
but but of the two
of the two what are you gonna do uh it's
true biscuit throwing three and a
quarter cause there's no way in hell
saquon barkley's gonna be held under 10
yards i can't imagine that no way yeah
know how that's gonna happen uh and and
you're right
when bud dupree is slashing through the
line on every play
you're not going to have a big night if
you're saquon barkley the steeler and
this is
this is part of the fun of week two we
start to get an understanding of
who was good who wasn't i think that i
don't want to get ahead of ourselves
here
we're taping later this morning the
joint pft pm chris sims unbuttoned pix
podcast
i you know the giants gave the steelers
a better game than the final score would
suggest
and the guaranteed rabbit right
out of their butt or elsewhere i i could
see the giants winning this game
i could too there's no doubt i was
thinking about it last night because you
know i want to whoop your butt in these
pics so i'm i'm thinking and uh
yeah i i this to me it's it's maybe the
bears have a little bit of the edge but
it's close to a coin flip type game for
me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports